If we are given this image and asked what
exactly this is, I am sure your answer will
be a “Cell”!
Now to study this, we need to study every
component present within.
And not only within, we even need to study
the covering that is this part in detail.
Can you tell me, what exactly is this named as?
That’s right!
It is called the cell membrane or the plasma membrane.
In our previous video we have learned that
the cell membrane is selectively permeable
in nature.
That is, it only allows specific materials
to enter and leave the cell.
Any guesses what is the plasma membrane made
up of?
The plasma membrane is made up of lipids and
proteins and also has some carbohydrate chains.
There are two things that freely move in and
out of the cell.
Those include Gases and Water!
Do you think these molecules need energy for
travelling across the membrane?
Let us take a simple example to understand
what exactly happens in this case.
We know what happens when a drop of ink is
added to a glass of water.
The single dark colored ink drop spreads when
added to water and the intense blue color
fades slightly.
If we see at the molecular level, then the
ink molecules, which are compactly packed
in the single drop get a chance of dispersing
in a larger area when added to the water.
This is nothing but the process of Diffusion.
And we know that this dispersal process does
not require energy.
The molecules just try to move freely in the
space available and as a result, diffusion
occurs!
The same story is seen when gas or water molecules
travel across the membrane!
Take carbon dioxide for example.
When cells undergo cellular respiration, a
lot of carbon dioxide accumulates in the cells.
On the other hand, there is a very little
carbon dioxide present outside the cells.
Hence the carbon dioxide molecules move outside
the cells.
Now, there is very little oxygen left after
respiration in the cells.
So the oxygen from outside the cells moves
in through the plasma membrane to make up
for the lost oxygen.
That means Carbon dioxide moves OUT and oxygen
moves IN!
Both the gases move from their area of higher
concentration to an area of lower concentration.
And this diffusion process does not require energy.
Diffusion is one of the processes by which
transportation of several substances is carried
out across the cell membrane.
But it is not the only one process on which
the cell relies.
There are a few more methods that the cell
adopts for transportation of substances.
Let us have a look at these processes in the next video!